all right good afternoon everyone
um
okay
we have a couple of Replacements today
representative goalie is sitting in for
representative leishman
and
Brian riddle is being replaced by John
McAllister thank you
and I think everyone else is here
nope there's representative Wilhelm okay
we have some information on the
retirement system from the retirement
system and from the retirement security
Coalition which is the professional
firefighters and others
so
and I apologize to everyone for not
being able to be here
last week my dentist would not let me go
and
so I hope to get to know most of you
better
for the agenda we need to continue the
organization by electing a vice chair
and a clerk
and so I'm accepting nominations for
representative Brad Senator Bradley uh I
would nominate uh my colleague on the
left Senator gray second okay is there
doesn't look like it in that case thank
you very much Vice chair right
uh and a
I I would like to appoint Brian rill as
clerk I've spoken to him and he's agreed
to it and his uh
Mr McCullough will be taking notes for
this meeting
the minute the draft minutes from the
previous meeting
are being posted on the
Committee website
which
are public once we approve them the
draft notice will be taken off and I'll
try to get the minutes posted after
every meeting so that they can be read
all right
the
we don't have a very long agenda but I
would like to make sure that we schedule
further meetings because
due to the legislative scheduling system
it is much easier to cancel or change a
meeting than it is to create one so I'd
like to suggest that we schedule a
meeting every week Thursday afternoon
unless there is a lot of opposition to
Senator Susie you look concerned I
thought Senator Bradley has microphone
off
oh that's okay
Senator did you wish to comment nope
okay
all right then we'll
um
sounds like there is no great objection
so I'll do that Thursday at 1 probably
here
the reason for the regular meetings is
that we have a very wide-ranging
charge here
and we'll need some time to figure out
exactly how to tackle it right not just
you know what are we going to do but how
are we going to do it and we have a
report due on December 1st
which will
just barely let us get some legislation
in
for this coming year
it um I know that the in the house
commit committees and commissions can go
to the rules committee and get late
introduced bills and that's probably
what we're going to have to do
so
that case we're down to the important
stuff the discussion
and does anyone have a have a comment or
concern or topic that I think we need to
bring to the commission
Senator Bradley
so
um
when
we debated this provision in the budget
um
Senator Susie brought forward an
amendment that
um I think is substantially similar to
what I am
you know gonna at least throw out there
and the reason for you know putting
something out there and I have two
different versions of it this is the
first version that's being circulated
and there should be enough copies for
members of the public
um I I think it's vitally important that
thank you that we actually have accurate
information
um the provision that the house passed
over to us in the budget
it came to us as
um
10 years 25 million dollars a year but
there were Actuarial analysis that said
if we pre-funded everything which is
what we did in 2022 with House Bill 1587
it was 134 million dollars and
I would prefer to do it something like
that so that there's no implication that
the state is going to
pass the cost of any new benefit back to
the counties or the municipalities I
think we would have to discuss what the
ongoing costs of the municipalities if
we get that far but in any case what you
have in front of you
is a version of Senator soucy's
Amendment which only increases the
multiplier to 2.5 percent for
those individuals and I believe they're
1824 of them that
had been hired
as group 2 employees prior to July 1 of
2011.
I think we need to get that costed out
the one change I think from Senator
soucy's amendment is I did not change
the existing retirement date as some of
the other versions
have done so that we have an analysis of
what
keeping the current 25 years of service
and 50-year age of retirement in place
I think that should be costed out
more or less what senator soucy
introduced with the exception of the
um
the
dates for the retirement of 25 years of
service and 50 years of age as I recall
from the debate that we had on the floor
in the Senate and the budget which the
Senate did not vote for it but I think
there was some indication that we should
examine it
so that is
what I would like to put out there for
discussion now
the policy of
the New Hampshire Retirement System in
the Department of administrative
Services is that without a actual bill
they can't go to the actuaries GRS and
acts for an Actuarial analysis and I
think if we're going to commit to the
kind of resources that
um you know are at stake here we need
good numbers I've spoken with the
speaker
we do
and we've spoken to our Chiefs of Staff
the two of us have the authority to
utilize consultant monies in the both
the house and the Senate
um
discretionary funds and we've spoken
about
the speaker Packard and I have spoken
about using that from my point of view I
am
more than happy to entertain that I
think we should do that because I think
that waiting until
January for a bill with an Actuarial
analysis is
um it just defeats the purpose of what
this commission should be about which is
collecting information and making
proposals
uh Marty Carlin who couldn't be here
today but folks from the retirement
system are here has told me that the
cost of an analysis like that is in the
upper range of about five thousand
dollars so I think it's something that
um is you know certainly something that
we can
afford to do and should do so that is
version number one
version number two uh Senator I think
that we should
um
see if there are any comments on them
okay fine
from other people before we look at
other other suggestions but I strongly
agree that once the commission agrees
that something is worth
analyzing we should get the Actuarial
analysis five or ten thousand dollars is
well worth
um the effort right so does anyone have
have a comment on this change this
this is only for group two who who were
retired were employed but not vested in
2011.
um Madam chair yes I um would just like
to agree 100 with uh Senator Bradley and
we I as he said we have talked about
this
and you know I think the biggest problem
that we had with Senator soucy's uh
Amendment at the last minute was we
really didn't have any numbers
and I'm not sure how we're going to
effectively move forward without the
numbers
and I'm sitting here today saying I want
to fix this thing once and for all
so whatever we need I hope that we can
attain so that we can do the job and do
somebody must say oh yes Mr mccola uh
McAllister thank you chairman that's
okay uh is it possible as well to look
into the the numbers and see if we can
run the numbers for
increasing the multiplier for all
members including the ones that had come
that's a that's a suggestion
um I think it's important to look at
those numbers as well uh since one of
the topics that we have been talking
about for many years now is the uh
recruitment as well as retaining members
in the fire service as well as police
I mean we certainly could look at it
I I think that all the bills that were
introduced As I understood them
um dealt with the 1824 people that were
hired prior
to July of 2011 so expanding it I think
um
while I understand that a lot of people
would like to do that and maybe a
retention benefit
um
I suspect the price tag is
extremely high and you will be
potentially pitting group two against
group one and we're suddenly into you
know a
Blockbuster spending initiative I think
that the focus
at least in my opinion would be much
better on the 1824 individuals that
um
had been hired
prior to January of 11 but if the
committee
wants to you know have that analysis
done I think that's not necessarily A
bad number to have but I doubt very much
that I would find
the ability to be able to support that
so I'm just being upfront about it right
now
and um actually I believe it's down to
1730 individuals
but anyway Senator Gray
uh certainly the discussions that we had
during the budget negotiations uh
covered a lot of different things
in the retirement system and certainly
retention is one of the things that we
looked at the proposal that we received
from the house I don't believe
did the right things in retention
because it actually made it easier for
people to retire earlier
and went back and did all the
retroactive things so for the bulk of
the employees covered in group two they
weren't mentioned they weren't addressed
and therefore it had no impact on them
one of the things I did ask the
retirement system to do is to look at a
plan that would at either 20 years or 30
years or whatever increase slightly the
multiplier for all employees so that to
people even in the affected individuals
the
1824 if you weren't up at at least a
2.25 that at 20 years you would go to
2.25 and then at say 30 years you would
go 2825 and if that were for all
employees
then certainly that could help the
retention of your employees
and it would help to reduce the cost
impact because the non-rail track
retroactivity okay means that I don't
have to go pay for
the reductions that we did before the
other thing that I did talk to people in
administrative Services about uh would
affect in my opinion both group one and
group two and that would be allowing for
a matching of contributions to the 401
403 Thrift Savings whatever you want to
call it but that would be a negotiated
benefit so that if
organization came in and said well yeah
we're ready to negotiate our new
contract and we would like five percent
two in match and three in you know wages
that that would be a possibility up to
whatever limit that we set and that
would be outside of the retirement
system itself but still
in keeping with a lot of the retirement
plans that are out there
um
right now I've looked at colas I've
looked at other things and certainly in
my opinion
it gets to be too expensive very quickly
so certainly interested in the numbers
coming out on a lot of this stuff but
like I say a match for
uh the employees who are making
contributions to some kind of a a
retirement plan uh
you know is something that would only
affect the state employees
on our dime it would be a negotiated
thing with the people who are employed
by the localities they would be
responsible for for theirs just as they
are other benefits so there's a lot of
issues out there and certainly Senator
Bradley has given us one so far he's got
more but there's a lot of things out
there but but to get this through the
Senate it has to be affordable and it
has to be sustainable
okay those are the the keys that I see
on getting a good vote in whatever we
come up with
in Senate thank you
but Senator Susie thank you madam chair
um a couple of things one um actually is
a question for Senator Bradley I'm
looking at the amendment that you
distributed which is in part similar to
the amendment that I had submitted at
the end of the budget process but I
noticed that you've taken out the
provisions relative to disability
retirement and I'm wondering if that was
intentional or not because that was part
of the amendment that I introduced it's
also part of Representative goalies bill
I'm not sure I can answer that question
right now I I intended the amendment to
be comprehensive so
um
if that
evidently is not in there it probably
should be it needs to address disability
okay and then if I may further I just
wanted to
um agree with
uh
Mr McAllister that if if we're going to
entertain the proposal I think it makes
good sense in terms of utilizing our
resources uh to make an ask that looks
at a broader array of numbers now I
agree that's not necessarily where we'll
end up but I think having the
information will help guide our decision
making more quickly and then I do hope
that given the as the chair identified
sort of the broad swath of
responsibility that we would also be
looking at other things such as a cola
that would impact a sustainable Cola
that would impact both groups that are
in the system I think that would
probably be the next topic I hope we
could address thank you madam chair yeah
I'd like to say that
this amendment and the other amendment I
believe Senator Bradley is bringing
forth is a short-term fix to deal with
some of the issues that were created by
the
um
severe problems we had in 2011. this is
a focused change
and it really only affects a small group
I'd like to spend the next meeting
essentially looking at what kind of
changes we might consider
to the retirement system in the longer
term and also how would we
what what priorities would we have what
would be our emphasis and what how would
we decide if it's a good change or a bad
change
I think we need to do that there are so
many choices and so many options and the
retirement system has so many moving
parts we need to narrow it down a little
so any anyone else have a comment on
this amendment
Senator Waters
thank you madam chair and just in a
sense to you know I want to thank
Senator Bradley for bringing this
forward and Senator Susie for the
framework that she provided for it and
my feeling aligns with what that you
just said Madam chair is that I would
hope that we could focus on two things I
think we ought to focus on what we might
potentially bring forward in the
framework of what Senator Bradley has
given us for but a bill the potential
could be done on veto day
I think we also then as you suggested
the next meeting look at the broader
context the larger issue of the
multipliers the colas I have some ideas
about doing an opt out instead of an
opt-in on the um additional 401 programs
which is you recall Madam chair we
discussed in the San Diego pension
commission and those other things and I
think that you know I think there is a
bifurcation about there what we might
potentially be able to do on veto day
and then what are what we might
recommend as bills will be introduced in
a regular session thank you okay thank
you
referred from all the senators does
okay
all the senatorial oars were in the
water
yes yes and I this is not just the
legislative commission so I'm hoping
that we had some other
comments about this plan I have one and
that's when we were talking when we were
considering changes this year
one issue that kept coming up
primarily with corrections but also with
other group too is the years of service
was it was an issue
they that
um
Massachusetts still has 20 years for 50
percent pay and
working an extra four years is a major
issue for some people and
I don't know if that's that's in your
other other plan Senator Bradley but uh
Mr McAllister you got a comment or
um no I don't have a comment on that um
but are we still brainstorming here okay
well in that case Senator your other
so
um thank you madam chair this version is
um slightly different than the previous
version and I think it is something that
um should also be looked at in terms of
the actuaries it
um
for anybody with less than five years of
service the multiplier of two one and
two two would go to
2.25 so it is obviously meant to
have less of a cost
um
which I think gets me to one of the big
picture items that you know this
Commission
and everybody that's on any of the
finance committees in the House and
Senate
um
is going to have to deal with as we
consider what we might do in terms of
retirement
those of us that are on the fiscal
committee heard a pretty compelling
uh testimony from the administrator or
the sununu
Center lawsuits that are ongoing and
as all of us that are legislators know
um Karen umberger's Bill the pass
dedicated 100 million dollars to
settling
those claims and I think
certainly Justice Broderick
has indicated that he feels that is
going to be too low
so that is a big picture item that
as we think about what we're going to do
here how we're going to pay for it we
have to be aware of we can't avoid
um that elephant in the room the second
thing
um
our revenue for July and July is one of
the smallest months of Revenue in the
year
I was off four million dollars I think
that we also need to be very cognizant
of where revenue is as this commission
unfolds its work especially if we're
going to
do something in the way that we did
House Bill 1587
in 2022 the beauty of House Bill 1587
was that
we put 42.9 million dollars into an
enhanced benefit for those tier B folks
in group two there's no question
of whether that funding you know will be
there to pay for that benefit a future
legislature can't send it down to the
municipalities or the counties and I
think that that is vitally important in
whatever we do
that it not be funded in the way that
the house sent us the budget which was
an allocation of 25 million dollars a
year for 10 years that's a recipe in my
opinion for
um
downshifting to the counties of
municipalities so
I I think we have to keep a very close
eye on revenue and I would Echo what
Senator gray said in terms of the Senate
um I think we want to solve this problem
but at the same time
um we have to have something that is
sustainable and affordable and if you
look back to you know where we were in
2011 and I really appreciate some of the
things that the municipal Association
has said about turning the corner
finally 12 years later with
um you know sustainability and rates
that
um employers pay and let's remember who
employers are employers are generally
for municipality schools and counties
are property taxpayers so we've made
significant progress and so to me
um
and the spirit of this amendment is to
make its hopefully a little bit more
affordable so that for those 1824 people
we might be able to get the consensus
going forward and that's why I would
hope that we would ask for it to be
comment
can I asked a question Madam chair yes
please
um so Senator Bradley you've heard some
suggestions about some other things to
be looked at and I I guess the question
would really be to you and the speaker
is um
before we'd you know have some
recommendation about what how broad
we're going to be looking at different
things like the the call or the
multiplier for everybody
um do you and the speaker believe that
the funding that you're looking at will
be adequate to cover
um several asks we've got two here and
then for the consultant yeah well I
think I think that and maybe the folks
in the retirement system can comment on
this
I I think that the funding necessary to
analyze these things because they're the
second one is the subset of the first
one should be relatively easy for the
actuaries to be able to determine and in
fact Mr Carlin has told me that I think
based on representative goalie's bill
which I
used as a way of drafting the amendment
that some of this analysis has already
been done so I I feel based there were a
number of options analyzed as we dealt
with House Bill 436 and what house bill
2. and some of that information is
available right now so we don't need to
repeat it right and the point I'm making
is that that consultant line should be
something that we can handle in our
budgets for these two
okay proposals more than that I think it
depends on you know how far we go what
retirement system it will cost obviously
a lot more than just changing this one
page
yeah I'm not going to thank America I'm
not opposed to uh extending it a little
bit but uh I I also question as to how
far we're gonna go uh I I understood
this uh commission to basically be re
try and find a problem for the
1834 people and I don't have a problem
whatsoever in moving forward and looking
at some other stuff but uh you know I
think we have to be realistically
careful as to how far I've been uh we
want to go
but I I think our primary goal ought to
be is is finding a fix for this
particular issue okay Madam chair yes
maybe just for the ease of our work that
perhaps the speaker and the president
could have some conversation before our
meeting next week and just figure out
you know what they what they think they
you know what range and what things
would be studied and uh that there will
because you're they're paying for it
so maybe that and then rather than us
deciding as a commission now what we
want looked at maybe there could be a
proposal they would bring in next week
that would cover the things they want to
cover
um I I that's fine I think they could
I think any major rewrite is going to
have to come in as a bill yeah a
separate bill I mean the commission
itself may offer May
sponsor a bill for this one issue and
probably will but
other people can
um
I'm sure there will be other bills I've
heard from several people that there's a
couple more in work right now so we'll
be dealing with those I'm glad and we'll
get the analyzes on those as the bill
rather than
part of the commission
thank you I I just want to point out I
mean I think group two is what prompted
the commission and the disagreement
between the house and the Senate on what
to include in the budget uh that's what
prompted it but ultimately we are
looking at a larger scope uh I think the
charge of the commission as outlined in
hb2
includes group one group two uh you know
colas uh you know the report of the uh
decennial retirement commission I mean
there's there's a fair number of items
on here and so
um yeah I think just for us to to look
at all of that and
uh make sure that we're
we're addressing yes group two but also
looking at uh the entire retirement
system as we work on on this
at least at a top level of what's what's
important and
um
and how to tell if it's a worthwhile
change that that's something that I
think we can brainstorm without
necessarily needing an Actuarial on
analysis
yes we do have more than this one one
issue even if it was the trigger
okay
any comments on this
I guess so the one thing I would say was
inadvertent on my part on the disability
issue that Senator Susie raised so I
think that
um
when we ask the retirement system to ask
GRS to look at that it that also should
be included as a separate line item in
the Actuarial analysis does that make
I just a question uh Madam chair would
you have any idea how long
uh or maybe if somebody can answer how
long it would take to get this
information that we're requesting
I know you work on this stuff all the
time
since they've done similar things I
would say
a couple of weeks would be my guess
um
we'll we'll keep in touch and find out I
I don't think it would be months
is there um
any practical way that we could possibly
lay out uh an agenda for the uh
coming meetings
uh maybe no not the whole you know until
the end but maybe every couple weeks
ahead of time so that the members might
be able to
um
look at what uh you know what we got
coming up and um you know maybe do any
analysis that they might have to do
um
[Music]
I'll have to consult with the retirement
system on when they would expect to have
the first analyzes ready because I think
that would be the first detailed meeting
when we say
this this is our some of our choices and
they cost X Y and Z and how which ones
do we want
um but I'll try to get something out
before next week
it's a good idea
[Music]
all right then we have two plans
of basic one change is the multiplier
one changes the
multiplier and changes the groups for
group two in the
tiered area and both would need
disability
so should we send those off for a
those in favor
aye opposed
okay we will send those two plans off
for an Actuarial analysis
basically high level and looking at what
other areas we should concentrate on and
what criteria we should use for
making changes
and so
does anyone else have anything
if they want to bring up mention or ask
about Senator gray uh I believe that the
retirement system did do some
calculations
on a increase in the multiplier you know
at uh 20 years of service and 30 years
of service and I think they already have
that so
um I don't know if it was an official
one or an off the Record one but if they
have those records that should also be
was saying that he has some of the
analyzes that were done last year and I
believe that was one of them that he
will be able to present to the
commission commission next week when
he's back from vacation
he was still still collecting them when
when he left
all right does anyone else have anything
that they want to bring up concerns
issues
well in that case we are adjourned and